hello everyone and welcome to Game three
of the rapids of the 2018 vultures
championship between Magnus Carlsen and
Fabiano Caruana
Carlson has two points in the lead this
is game 3 it's 2 to 0 for Carlson if you
haven't checked out the first two games
I will put a link to them in the
description but also be sure to check
that out as well and I haven't been
including any photos so far as I'm
basically just showing you the games as
they were played but I will show one as
it's a very nice to have it as a photo
challenge so here it is who is the
person making the first move for Carlson
there you have it now Caruana has the
black pieces and to get back into this
match to even reach the blitz mini
matches he now has to win two games in a
row against Carlson he starts this game
with the black pieces so in this game he
needs the win Coulson knows it and he
will make it as hard for him as possible
so let's see how the game went Carlson
opens with e4 we have c5 caravana again
goes for the Sicilian as now there's no
more time for Caruana to to even try
going for the for the comp a trove
Knight to f3 we have e 6 and C for the
Kramnik variation we have Knight to c6 b
4c capture some d4 Knight capture some
d4 and now Bishop to c5 and Carson goes
Knights to c2 from C to the knight a
dozen excellent job controlling be for
d4 in d3 a lot of very nice squares so a
knight to f6 and already we have a new
move in in the position I was not able
to find this move anywhere in the
database and the Knight to c3 now we
have this very nice Marazzi motif where
Coulson will do everything he can to
control the d5 square the Queen the
night both of the pawns are controlling
d5 and he basically says you are not
pushing d5 in this game and you know I'm
perfectly satisfied with a draw if you
draw this game against me I'm a world
champion
we have castles by Caruana Bishop to e3
offering a trade of bishops and now b6
and cousin goes Bishop to e2 you don't
really gain anything by exchanging here
you will simply promote a beep on to a
more central C phone and after something
like Bishop to d3 now black can play d6
black will enjoy a very nice poem Center
so after b6 Bishop to e2 and the now
comes rush up to be 7 so Carlson will
most likely Castle kingside and Corona
does have a very nice bishop pair eyeing
at Carlson's King side but you know it's
much too early for such conversations we
have castles by Carlsen Queen to e7
developing a queen connecting rooks also
the queen is now guarding leadership on
c5 so perhaps even Queen captures on see
if I will be possible although unlikely
Queen to d2 cousin does the same and now
rook F to d8 karana would very much
enjoy pushing d5 at some point we have
looked at d1 by Carlsen Knights the e5
and now comes Bishop captures on c5 pawn
captures on c5 and now f4 cousin forces
caranas nice to move from this very nice
central square that is e 5 nights to g6
and now Queen to e3 giving more
protection to the e4 pawn as it is
attacked by them both the night and the
bishop here we have d6 and now comes
Luke to d2 across and now of course
wants to double up on the D file and
Cora wanna will try to do the same
first a6 taking away the be 5 square
from Collins night
we have rook a to D 1 and now Queen
Queen back to c7 at some point if ideas
might come that if d5 is played then the
night from g6 and Queen will both be
attacking the pawn on f4 we have b3 and
now comes h6 we have g3 by cross and now
reinforcing the idea for pawn also
controlling the h4 square taking it away
from the knight and here we have rook to
these 7 karana makes room for the other
rook to enter the game
Bishop to f3 other a nice move
controlling the e4 square but also at
some point if cousin does push a 5 then
also the bishops will you know attack
each other and here rook to e8 first
perhaps karana is considering to push a
5 but there is always time to move the
robach to d4 to d8
you can't really play a move you would
usually play because
well Carson is more than satisfied with
a draw a draw wins him the World Chess
Championship the World Champion title so
Queen to f2 by Carlson we have Knights
to e7 and here h3 taking away the g4
square even further from the night but
also at some variations preparing g4
rookie to the 8th now Khurana does
double up on the D file and here Russia
back to g2 we have Knight to c6 and now
good ideas of perhaps pushing e5 himself
the knight is now nicely controlling d4
but night the b4 might also be an idea
in the future but Carson here is not
satisfied he doesn't want to repeat
moves with Bishop to f3 rather he goes
for the win he goes with g4 we have
Queen to a5 and here Khurana did he has
to try something but there's not a lot
of things he can do he can't push any of
the pawn said the pawn moves are not
possible he can't really improve the
position of his pieces I mean the roofs
are the roofs are simply too good on the
D file also they do have to protect the
D pawn so you have to try something
Queen - if I was played but now across
and strikes with a very nice move Knight
to a4 and now you can see that if he 5
ever comes then after pawn captures the
c5 pawn will become very weak but there
is an even greater threat for example if
Khurana does a slow move here let's say
something like Bishop to a8 just the
waiting move then g5 is very dangerous
pawn captures pawn captures Knight has
to move and after the knight moves now
you don't even have to create any
weaknesses you can simply capture on c5
and black cannot recapture if he
recaptures then he loses the whole rook
here after rook captures on d7 so after
Knight a 4 karana simply decided to go
back we have Queen to c7 and now comes a
5 by Carson
deciding to trade everything down and
simply enjoy his position D captures on
e5 Knight captures on c5 forcing a rook
trade rook captures rook captures rook
captures and Queen captures here for the
time being across and controls the D
file and also he would very much enjoy
capturing the bishop on b7 so Caruana
moves it if you play it characters on f4
too soon
then first night captures Queen captures
and then as the bishop is already very
nicely attacking the knight here queen
d6 with a double attack against the
night and also it's it's just a very
nice position okay what black can get
out with check but then then you can
recapture on f4 so nothing really going
on here
but as Cora wanna can't afford to trade
any further pieces and he really does
like his very strong Bishop Bishop to
a8f captures on e5 and now Queen
captures on e5 by Caruana Knight
captures on e5 is also a possibility
because it opens up an attack against
Coulson's night and c5 but then let's
say you play Bishop characters on e8 now
capturing on c5 would in fact be good
for black this comes with two check but
the problem is white will not capture
immediately first Causton would capture
on e6 and only then after pawn captures
capture here and then after Knight
captures on c4 you don't want to allow
this Knights to be it to be stay
undefended a knight captures pawn
captures and after Queen to a7 check
king or queen will block and now you
will grab another pawn but after Queen
captures on e6 white will again be up
upon so nothing good to be done here for
black so instead the Caruana goes for
Queen captures on e4 and this is in fact
the strongest idea Knight to d7 by
Carlsen here cross and had the
possibility to capture the a sex pawn
but he calculates precisely that he
doesn't need it he goes Knight to d7
offers a trade of knights also this
comes with an attack on the Queen but he
allows this very nice infiltrating move
with Queen to b2 and after Queen to be
two we have Queen to d6 by Carlsen again
offering the Queen to capture on c2 but
if Queen captures on c2 you get Queen to
f8 check and this is a force first draw
after King moves Knight captures with
check captures and now Queen captures on
f7 white can force a perpetual and a
draw is enough here for Carlsen
let me just fix that
so after Queen Queen 2d6 we have knife
captures on d7 Queen captures on d7 and
now Queen capture son d2 and now comes
Queen to e8 check King h7 and Queen
captures on a a so here although it
seems very dangerous Carlsen does have
better pieces his Bishop is very strong
but then again his King is somewhat
feeling the draft and if this night can
come into the game could be very
dangerous
so Queen to d1 check by Caruana King
gauge 2 and Queen to d6 check King to h1
and now comes Knight to d4 this night is
coming closer and closer and it could
get very dangerous if this night for
example can come to e to Queen D 1 check
Queen G 1 could be could be very
dangerous so Queen to e4 check by
Carlsen we have f5 and now G captures on
f5 Knight captures on f5 is possible but
Khurana has different plans for this
night with captures on f5 and now Queen
back to e3
Knights to e6 by Caruana and now comes
the be for a very nice move because of
course you cannot capture the night will
be hanging on e6 so after before we have
Knight to g5 and here the queen is very
nicely controlling the f4 square if
Khurana can get f4 in and f3 that would
be very good for black so Carson doesn't
waste any time we have c5 attacking
Carwin as Queen Queen to f6 and now c6
the bishop is very nicely controlling
this pawn and here we have Knight back
to e6 here we also a possibility was f4
it seems like a very nice move
threatening f3 but Carson simply gets
too much after the squinted III check
King to h8 and now after c7 c8 is coming
there's really no way to prevent to this
f3 would just be too slow so after c6 we
have Knights to e6 and now comes a
four-night the c7 by Caruana we have
Queen to f4 attacking the knight and c7
and now Knight back to e6 here we have
Queen to d6 as you can see the moves
were repeated here from e3 we had Knight
c7 Queen f4 and now a corona play
tonight back to e6 and cross and
actually could repeat here with Queen to
e3 and then as
Khurana do you want a draw by repetition
with Knight to c7 or will you try and
figure out something else everything
else is just bad as you do have to
prevent this pond from coming to b5 but
Carson actually goes for the active line
Queen to b6 and now comes Queen to a1
Czech koruna has to try something came
to h2 and now comes Knights to d4 calls
and pushes is passed pawn as of course
past bonds must be pushed c7 and here
Quintus III by Caruana interestingly if
92 yes you are threatening Queen to g1
checkmate but Queen c5 simply prevents
the Queen from coming to g1 and also
prepares upon the c8 with Queen
so after c7 we have Queen to c3
preventing the pond to be Queen dance
yet but here cross and simple place
Queen to see what c5 and here black
really has no moves if you trade Queens
then it's all over white will just bring
another Queen into the game so Caruana
has to try something he's extremely low
on the clock and everything is against
him he's down two points in the match
and this is just it was just hard to
watch this he played Queen to e3 he he
has to try and make something happen
okay if cousin plays a slow moved and
still it's simply not enough cross and
plays see it he brings another Queen
into the game we have f4 here by Caruana
and now cousin simply plays Queen back
to G for not allowing f3 although not
that f3 was any kind of a threat but
here with two queens on the board
Caruana decided to resign game 3 and it
was basically in this position unmoved
51 that Fabiano Caruana resigned the
game Magnus Carlsen won the third game
of the rapid and with three games in a
four game match
Magnus Carlsen is the 2018 World Chess
Champion so he managed to remain his
everything in his title and yeah it was
it was really exciting after after 12
games of classical you know no cracks in
the armor were made 12 draws in 12th
class of the games now Carson is
presented with this opportunity to try
and go for it in a quicker time format
and he manages to beat Fabiana with with
3 to 0 ok this third game wasn't so
as Caruana basically couldn't afford the
draw so he had to push push push and
then this is what happens but yeah such
is life and you know such were the rules
of this World Chess Championship event
so yeah very interesting and you know
this is the this is now after after the
match with Carrick in this is now again
the second time Coulson wins his title
not in the classical time format but
rather as the classical time format was
drawn in the Rapids so it's interesting
will will feed I do something about this
maybe add more games to the classical
time form and maybe change something I
don't know
are you satisfied with how things are
now or would you prefer something else
and it's if you think about it when
Carlson played against Anandi - in 2013
he won the match without losing a single
game then in the return match with Anand
in 2014 Anand won one game then in the
match against Karthik in only one game
was lost you know cousin would lost only
one game and now against kurakin again
he didn't lose a single game so if you
think about it in for vulture
championship matches
cousin lost two games so that's
basically half a game per World Chess
Championship match that's definitely not
bad but yeah like I said the videos were
a bit shorter but these are rapid games
and I decided to show them as they are
being played the rather than you know
just waiting and doing tomorrow or
something like that so I I do hope you
didn't mind that and I do hope you
enjoyed the the rapid uploads as well as
the rapid games I would also like to
thank Alexandre spot is a lava rod I'm a
Leo called looper a Thomas mystic and
better Branning Meyer for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon
as the World Chess Championship is over
now we will enjoy some games from your
suggestions prepare a different a
different series and also the world
blitz and rapid championship are
approaching so we're gonna enjoy that as
well pretty soon so thank you all and I
will see you soon